hiring great people is core to every
business but finding the right talent is
often the tricky part traditional job
sites aim to help people find jobs and
jobs find people but can have difficulty
returning relevant results let's dive
into how you can use Google's cloud
talent solution to leverage machine
learning and create a better job search
experience see large companies may have
their own internal hiring and recruiting
teams whereas smaller companies might
use off-the-shelf talent solutions but
both want quality results for candidates
and job postings trying to match these
together may sound simple on the surface
but traditional keyword searching is too
simplistic and gets choked up in some
situations such as hidden or extraneous
keywords also known as keyword stuffing
job postings that require five years of
experience in a technology that's really
only been around for two years and
things like typos acronyms and overuse
of technical jargon what exactly is a
wreck and asset prot one ultimately
these lead to poor experiences and bad
candidate fits so Google used machine
learning also called ml to create a
customizable job searching experience
the cloud talent solution job search API
is designed to power the job search
experience with built-in machine
learning algorithms in short you send
your job listing information over such
as the company and job details to the
job search API the API analyzes the job
data to develop an understanding of the
jobs once jobs have been indexed by the
API you can search against the jobs and
get search results by relevance or other
sorting preferences which we'll talk
about in future videos there are four
common use cases that typically leverage
a solution like this job boards where
the site returns a list of jobs to job
seekers career site providers that
provide career site services to client
companies staffing agencies which
provide short or long term employees to
clients and applicant tracking systems
which are used by companies to track
applicants through the hiring process
the job search API is designed to be
modified to best fit with your needs and
the api's performance can vary
significantly based on how its
configured also it's worth noting that
the job search API is not to be confused
with the jobs indexing API that
facilitates jobs showing up on
google.com search
there's a separate indexing API to have
job listings show up on searches that
people make on google.com there's a link
for this in the description if you want
to learn more about that but the cloud
talent solution job search API does much
more when it's integrated into your job
search solution with all that being said
let's talk about how to actually
implement the job search API in our next
video we'll go over the API in greater
detail planning steps and talk more
about implementation strategies thanks
for watching and remember when looking
for talent it's ok to keep your head in
the cloud